everyone and welcome to my why python 3
video
this video is also going to serve as the
first video in my python 3 programming
tutorial series though there will be
nothing more than just information on
python 3 versus python 2 in this video
and why you would you should choose
python 3.
video 2 will begin with the downloading
and installation of python 3. also i'm
going to mention here and again later on
in the series
uh that the series is going to be geared
towards the complete noob for python so
if you're used to python 2 7 already
making the transition to python 3 is is
really not that difficult i will
probably make a pi 2 to pi 3
transitional video after i finish this
series but that's probably a little bit
away so on with the video
why python 3 so throughout my time with
python programming i've visited and
revisited the idea of python 3
countless times
when i first started i that's exactly
what i did and i've always come up with
the exact same answer every time python
3 on the whole is not better than python
2 yet it has less support documentation
in libraries basically all the good
things
in python 3 for the most part not all of
them but a lot of them have actually
been ported backwards into python 2.
so
more on why that might must be really
frustrating later but anyways a few
months ago i watched a youtube video of
a presentation about why one should
choose python 3. uh it was something
like trust you know why python 3. trust
me it's better something like that right
and it was given by an actual developer
for python 3.
through the entire presentation now
given it's probably just the case that
because i'm not an expert or a
professional
i guess professional is a bad word i am
a professional but i'm not an expert
through the entire presentation
i was still left
not really seeing any reason based on
that presentation and what was said in
that presentation i saw no reason to
switch right but instead i could i could
really sense like the frustration in
this guy's voice right the lack of
adoption for python 3 is actually an
interesting topic of discussion right
the story of python 3 could make like a
nerdy greek tragedy movie or something
seriously
now this stuff said you know i'm not
suggesting people move to python 3 out
of pity that's not a very valid reason
or a good idea at all but
there are some good reasons why you
should move to python 3. see python 3 is
really the future python 2
is not if if you
um if you stick with python 2 and python
2 only and everybody does this you're
going to be able to get away with it for
a while and then you'll find yourself
using python 2 in a time where it's
comparable to using something like
pascal today right
at the same time python itself will
probably fall behind as a developmental
language or a programming language just
simply due to the lack of support and
community overall
you know python in my honest opinion is
is simply the best language out there
it's it's very high level and yet it has
incredible power and due to its high
level nature it's also very simplistic
it's just a great language and it would
be a shame to really see it become
outdated just simply because the
community was disinterested in moving
forward with the language and i you know
i really can't imagine how annoying it
must be for for the pi 3 developers you
know that people just simply aren't
adopting the new language for
not too great of reasoning in my opinion
so
in the end the deciding factor for me to
not adopt python 3 was the lack of
documentation and support right it was
when i was a noob to programming in
python and i really needed that support
just as anybody new to any language
needs some sort of you need the
community and the support
in order to progress in that language
right
and i looked at both languages and to me
they seemed
equal right equal but the community
surrounding them was very different in
size so it seemed to make sense for me
as a noob to go with python27
and i believe that's a logic i think
that was a very logical choice and so
anybody else that's doing the same thing
i completely sympathize with why why
that is the choice at the moment
now that i'm someone that you know has
had this channel and i'm making all
these videos on youtube
i seem to be doing something right
enough to where at least a decent amount
of people
enjoy how i teach and i think it's
almost
somewhat of my responsibility to share
and teach python 3 at this point this
way maybe in the future when you know
someone
does a search for python 3 versus python
2 7 maybe they'll find my video or maybe
they'll find stuff from people that i
helped get started or
or
you know whatever and python 3 can
actually start to grow you know because
for the most part right now when you
hear a python 3 versus python 2
discussion the differences are really
only geared towards
i would say the expert or at least
professional python developer but i
would argue most professional python
developers couldn't care less about
these tiny differences
and then the main question of
performance is is pi 3 or pi 2 faster
they are pretty much
equal all the way down so there was in
that in the video from
the guy and trust me uh pi three is
better i forget the title but
um
in that video he does compare you know
the performance and depending on the
task sometimes pi2 is faster sometimes
pi 3 is faster the differences are so
minut that performance isn't the issue
so it really comes down to a few uh just
tiny differences that at the moment are
so tiny that it just doesn't make sense
but i in the future
um if python 3 is allowed to continue
growth and development python 3 will be
the victor but if obviously no one
supports it then that sort of stuff is
never going to happen and you won't have
modules and all this kind of stuff
so
um
back to you know a video like like this
guy though you know by this time you
know that video is kind of geared
towards at least you know most likely an
expert and and by that time that you
know pi 3 makes sense to the expert the
developer has already gone through their
noob stage and probably did the whole
python 2 versus python 3 decided pi 2
was the best start and then got
ingrained in their ways right and then
it's very hard to get them to switch and
a lot of people don't see a reason to
switch
so here my goal is to offer a full slew
of beginner and
partially intermediate python tutorials
all using python 3 right so my python 27
tutorials will remain here i'm not going
to delete them or anything
but i'm going to be doing my best to
offer the same topics only in python 3
and uh some modules uh that are pretty
popular in python 2 still aren't
available in python 3 so we can work on
at least probably covering at least one
of those modules as far as like how you
could port them because really porting
them isn't that big of a deal
some of them are harder than others but
anyway
this way
hopefully you'll be able to get through
that noob and intermediate stage of
learning uh python and you'll be able to
do it with python 3. so with that let's
go ahead and start python
as always everyone thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions until the next video